CHARLOTTE.
TWO OR THREE YEARS, SOME OF THE
GREATS START, IT WILL BE WIDE
OPEN, WIDE OPEN.
>> THE DRAFT CLASS OF HAM AND
EDWARDS, MAN, A LOT OF TALENT IN
THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU LOOK ACROSS THE BOARD.
YOU THINK ABOUT ANTHONY EDWARDS
AND LaMELO AND THOSE ARE LIKE
GENERATIONAL TYPE PLAYERS.
YOU KNOW?
WITH GENERATIONAL TYPE
CONFIDENCE.
I THINK SHAQ TALKS ABOUT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A CERTAIN
PERSONALITY AND A CERTAIN
CONFIDENCE TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE LEAGUE.
>> YEAH.
THEY ARE BOTH -- -- AND MELO
FIGHTING TO BE THE FACE OF OUR
LEAGUE.
THEY BOTH HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO
SAY IT AND THEY HAVE THE TALENT
TO BACK IT UP.
AND DO IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE AMAZING TO SEE
THESE GUYS GROW.
>> I'LL BE WATCHING.
>> CLOSELY.
>> NOT AFRAID --
>> WHO IS YOUR FIRST PICK?
>> FIRST PICK WHAT?
>> MELO OR ANT?
>> I CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
>> WOW.
>> LIKE YOU PICK YOUR TIES.
CLOSE YOUR EYES.
>> I'M NOT WEARI